[Music]
this is Michelle Kaz bun she's an
engineer at Google on the cube flow team
and this is John Bohannon he's the
director of science at primer an AI
start-up my team at primer built a
machine learning system that reads
millions of news articles and tells you
what it learns and I worked with them to
deploy this system of cube flow to make
it portable and scalable the goal is to
create a machine to help humans learn
about the world and overcome their
biases humans are biased consider this
riddle a boy and his father are in a car
crash the father is killed instantly
the boy is rushed to the hospital and
prep for surgery with one of the best
doctors in the country the doctor
arrives sees the boy on the table and
says I can't operate on this patient
he's my son who's the doctor it's a
paradox right father's dead so it's the
boy's mother for those playing at home
don't feel bad
85% of people are stumped by this
question it even worked on Michelle when
she first heard it bias is powerful
all humans habits and we all have to
work against it constantly every time
you meet someone you can't help but make
assumptions but you're probably biased
wait that one's actually mine and that
one's mine oh you're totally biased any
system built on human decisions will
inherit human bites consider Wikipedia
it has grown into the world's most
important general-purpose information
resource but there's no one in charge
information is added to Wikipedia day
after day by millions of volunteers it
just boggles the mind that such a thing
can exist and that it actually works
Wikipedia aims to be the summary of all
human knowledge but it has biases just
like the humans who create it if you
think about all the new things we learn
about the world each day keeping
Wikipedia up to date seems impossible
it's not just that important information
is missing for most articles but it's
that many important articles haven't
been written at all which shouldn't be
that surprising right Wow
so they're about 5 million Wikipedia
in English alone yep and there are some
thousands of news articles published
every day hundreds of thousands just in
English so you just have to read all of
it you find the important information
that's in one set and doesn't exist in
the other okay yeah that's hard machine
learning to the rescue I decided to
start by focusing on people we want a
system that just reads all the news
every day and learns new information
about everyone not only people described
in Wikipedia but anyone described in the
news and if there's enough significant
information about someone in the news
who's missing from Wikipedia the system
should just write you the first draft of
the article the goal is to make it as
easy as possible for the human editors
of Wikipedia to do their job and first
step is to shine a really bright light
so we can see where our bias is for
example well for example only about 15%
of Wikipedia's biographical articles are
about women and that gender gap is
especially bad for scientists if you
never hear about all the amazing women
of science and engineering then it
reinforces your bias about those
professions exactly and that's why I
wanted to work with primer on this in
the first place right and here we are
just a few weeks later and we're
actually catching up on where we are
with deployment so where we left off we
had this really cool ml system with some
really classic ml deployment problems q
blow to the rescue our first problem was
scaling so the computing load is all
over the map on this one on any given
day were like processing hundreds of
thousands of documents news articles
scientific papers and we're updating
information about people in our
knowledge base but we also have users
who might want to add thousands of new
people all at once and that kicks off a
backfill of information about those
people from millions of historical
documents this turned out to be easy to
solve because your team had already set
up a kubernetes cluster a queue flow is
built on kubernetes because scalability
is baked into the platform so the
application backend was built on top of
Postgres which was a straightforward
migration into cloud sequel once the
data was migrated I transplanted the
full app into kubernetes engine I
started with a single node cluster and
enabled Auto
which scales the size of the cluster up
and down based on resource requests so
now we can deal with unpredictable and
bursty computing loads like yours ok but
on top of the scaling problem I have
also got a complexity problem so our
data pipeline has a bunch of spaghetti
junctions and not only do we have
thousands of models to load at inference
time but we have to update those models
as new information comes in
so at training it adds up to like
millions of model features getting
updated every day I noticed that luckily
this is exactly what queue flow is
designed for composability the platform
provides patterns for reusing common ml
tasks like updating models incrementally
in the background I started by carving
out pieces of the app for example model
training was refactored into a separate
service that uses cube flow operators
the monolith is now separated into
smaller distinct pieces now it's a
pipeline with three separate steps
trained serve and web app oh that sounds
much nicer okay so how's it looking so
far well the refactoring immediately
reduced the training runtime so that
translates directly to cost savings and
now you don't have to run huge nodes all
the time because gke takes care of the
scaling for you the other win is the
decrease in code complexity that
translates to less maintenance overhead
less time searching for the source of
bugs less time on ramping new engineers
and adding new features okay but that
creates a new problem what happened I
thought of so you know now we have all
this save time what am I gonna do with
all the time you could create some
Wikipedia articles about women of
science mmm good call oh and what about
the last thing on my wish list about
vendor lock-in we don't want our system
tied to one cloud infrastructure we want
it to be able to deploy anywhere even on
Prem oh and bonus points if the solution
is free and open source check and check
as long as you're running standard open
source kubernetes you can run kids low
weight key flows open source yes
thanks for listening I hope that hearing
about this project lowers the bar for
trying it yourself the cube flow
community has some great resources for
getting started which you can find at Q
flu org and hey got a few minutes every
time I've already used this machine
learning system to identify thousands of
notable women of science who are missing
from Wikipedia you can make a difference
right now just follow this link and see
what the machine is discovered for you
go fill in a gap in the world's
knowledge
[Music]
you